DANIEL PHAM: Hi.
My name is Daniel Pham, and
welcome to This Week in Android
Development for Monday,
January 13, 2014.
Over the past few
weeks, we've been
hard at work making Android
better, faster, and stronger.
That doesn't mean we weren't in
the studio producing episodes
of your favorite
content, though.
So make sure you check
out Android Design
in Action's recap of all
their shows from 2013.
We also had Nazmul and Paul
Saxman explain what context is
and why it matters
on an episode of UXD.
Todd continues his
infiltration with Lesson 2.2
in his series on
Play Games for iOS.
And finally, Dan
Lavelle introduced us
all to a new series
we're calling PlayBytes.
Not to be forgotten, our team
members in Japan and Korea
released a few dev and
design bytes as well,
including ActionBarCompat
and ChromiumWebView,
in both Japanese and Korean.
We've got a ton of
new content coming out
in the next few weeks,
so make sure you
subscribe to our channel.
That's all for this week
in Android Development.
I'm Daniel Pham.
It's in the palm of
your hand now, baby.
It's a yes or a no; no maybe.